what you have just seen our films made
by hidden motion picture cameras during
actual bank robberies the cameras were
generally turned on by the same switch
that activated the silent alarm during
the course of the robbery because the
films were made with a fixed camera and
preset exposure and focus they do not
quite meet Hollywood standards
nevertheless they are proven to be
useful tools for protection against one
of the major crimes with an FBI
jurisdiction not only are the armed
robberies of financial institutions
serious crimes but even more serious
offenses are often associated with them
assault kidnapping or murder of bank
employees or bystanders the situation
became so serious that the President
signed into law the bank Protection Act
of 1968 this Act required various
federal regulatory agencies to establish
minimum standards for security devices
and procedures in the financial
institutions under their supervision
these included among other things
alarm installations maintenance of
traceable bait money and every tellers
cash drawer and tamper resistant locks
in addition many banks have installed
surveillance motion picture cameras some
results of which you have seen and
hidden steal cameras which provide
pictures that can be blown up such
photographs can be extremely valuable in
the investigation of a bank robbery but
the most useful device for the
identification and apprehension of bank
robbers is still the human eye and the
human mind properly trained and
intelligently used even under situations
of great stress again we will run some
films made during actual bank robberies
and see what can be learned about what
you should or should not do in these
situations
roll film please looking down the muzzle
of a gun may interfere with your powers
of observation yet the identification
and apprehension of the robbers must
almost certainly depend upon the
completeness and accuracy of the
description furnished by witnesses who
had the best opportunity for observation
during the face-to-face confrontation
but first hand observation becomes less
valuable the moment it stops being
firsthand with tension relaxed its
natural for witnesses to explode into
speech to compare their widely differing
impressions of what actually happened
the longer they talk and the more
versions of the robbers appearance and
actions are introduced the more confused
each witness own recollection may become
by the time police officers arrive to
begin their investigation it is almost
impossible to sort out individual
observation from consensus opinion
preserving the crime scene after the
robbery is just as important as
preserving the individual observation
made during it every bank employee
should be trained not to touch any part
of the crime scene until law enforcement
officers arrive and to protect it from
casual passers-by the marble floor may
yield heel prints which can be
photographed and later compared with
those of a suspect the counter of the
tellers cage almost certainly retains
fingerprints from the unloved hand of
the robber who vaulted it
the description by witnesses and the
physical evidence at the crime scene are
the two most important elements in bank
robbery investigations the foundation
upon which law officers must build their
case what can you do to help them let's
look at some situations in more detail
first you can observe closely the closer
the confrontation the more you should
see to be able to do this under stress
you should make a mental checklist now
so that you know what to look for
physical features like height build
complexion hair and eye colors voice and
accent mannerisms scars malformations or
other peculiarities dress description of
the weapon and holdup note the film's
you have seen should have convinced you
how important it is to safeguard your
observation as soon as possible after
the robbery write down descriptions of
the robbers your recollection of what
happened and every other impression
while it's still fresh in your mind only
in this way can you provide the
investigating officer a truly first-hand
account without it being distorted by a
group discussion the preservation of
physical evidence so essential to bank
robbery investigations can be summarized
in three words
don't touch anything except for
ministering to the injured preserve the
crime-scene intact for trained
investigators the techniques they use in
handling the physical evidence and the
laboratory facilities that they have
available for its analysis can often
provide the information that breaks the
case if it reaches them from the crime
scene uncontaminated a hold of note like
this left behind by the robber may
provide a host of clues latent
fingerprints identification of
handwriting paper modus operandi from
bank holdup note files this one actually
did lead to the arrest of a bank robber
he was convicted and sentenced to a
federal penitentiary
certainly there are other useful things
you can do to aid law enforcement
officers to reduce the increasing toll
of bank robberies whenever possible
teller should include properly recorded
bait money with the loot they should
also whenever possible
activate the silent alarm and
surveillance systems and all witnesses
should attempt to observe the direction
of the robbers escape and the make and
license number of his getaway car but
none of these actions should be
attempted if they increase the danger to
the bank employee or others what you can
always do if you witness a bank robbery
is to observe closely recall accurately
preserve carefully
you